and
we met such bombings New I think
Putin
they are
Yana I think it’s so
hot I
watched it we still skips times in the entire
history of our Ukraine for our Ukrainian
history of moderation Muscovites and
Nikola
trust nothing and that’s it, we’ll just have
a beautiful wrapper on the track in the next
since Russia is trying to show itself
as a
country that wants to end the conflict
but not do anything for this, therefore
it’s all on my mind, in my opinion this
is another Dim’s deception for Galina, you can
Vera, you’re just one of their words, because in the
evening saying that the anecdote itself is on Russia and
Russian communism
I think that we can grow our own there,
we can recognize
our cream Donbass and a hit on our
swamps in our province to raise the
fire of good